the MVP odds are out for 20/20 courtesy
of the Westgate sports book Lamar
Jackson the 2019 NFL MVP six to one to
win it again but he's not the favorite
the favorite the reigning Super Bowl MVP
packed four homes the 2018 MVP he is 4
to 1 followed by Russell Wilson 10 to 1
to Sean Watson 12 to 1 dak Prescott
Carson Wentz 16 to 1
drew Brees who hasn't even decided
whether I was gonna play this year he's
20 to 1 along with Aaron Rodgers and
Kyler Murray that's a Kyler Murray
that's a that's an interesting name in
that spot and then Christian McCaffrey
in Ezekiel Elliott at 30 to 1 guys I
look I can understand why my home would
be the favorite if he was healthy all
year in 2019 who knows if he would have
toppled Lamar Jackson for MVP it would
have taken a special season because
Lamar Jackson was incredible but I don't
I don't think it's all that crazy to
think it's gonna be one of those two
guys in 2020 I think but I think those
odds are logical my first thought when I
looked at is Tom Brady is watching our
show this morning and he is ticked off
he's not even 30 to 1 and he might be
listen he is he is he's 31 yeah I
thought I didn't see him on that list he
was running electively editing that was
that was a that was that that was the
next topic after this one but but but go
ahead well it's a good point yeah hey
well it's guys gonna find motivation
anywhere he'll find it in this and not
only that not only that but he's not
going to play for the Browns
I mean he's not whoever he goes to play
for and it might be the Patriots is
surely going to be a contender to play
football in January so a quarterback
who's probably gonna make the playoffs
it's weird that he would not be on that
list but I'll just say this I would pick
Russell Wilson on Monday in my column I
wrote a note that's saying that Russell
Wilson drafted in 2012 the Seahawks that
played 143 games
since 2012 Russell Wilson has started
every one of them he's got a better
winning percentage in his career than
Aaron Rodgers or Drew Brees and he's
made the playoffs in seven of eight
years and he's been to two Super Bowls
Russell Wilson in eight years has gotten
exactly zero MVP votes and for those who
don't know the MVP vote there are 50
voters every year you vote for one guy
autos it's not like baseball where you
vote you know on a sliding scale from
one to ten in football you vote for one
there's 50 guys so since Russell Wilson
broke into the NFL and started starting
and starting started leading the
Seahawks to the playoffs
there has been 400 MVP votes altogether
and he's never got one but I think he's
gonna get off the schneid in 2020 yeah
well I mean it's a you know it's amazing
really with the year yet this year that
he didn't get one or two votes but I get
it because it was that special of the
year by Lamar Jackson so yeah he you
know he should have or what did he win
the unanimous MVP right he won unanimous
em yeah bro he's one of two players him
and Tom Brady in what 2010 yeah won the
MVP unanimously yeah well you know I
look at this list and the thing that I
just that jumps out to me and again I
think it is a very logical realistic
list here I just feel like the guys the
top four on the list are so much better
than everybody else on the list it's
just I just think it's one of these guys
I do
I think mahomes Jackson Wilson Watson
are you know clearly the four best
quarterbacks in football right now they
can do it by themselves it doesn't
matter what's going on around them they
can pretty much make plays and carry the
offense consistently you know on a
week-to-week basis and you know I'm with
you I hear the Russell Wilson thing III
just think this is just lining up for
you know greatness or Patrick mahomes I
think that's gonna be one of these
things where the pressures off I've won
a Super Bowl I've won a regular season
MVP and I think this team is gonna
thrive with oh we're great and we have a
chance to be even greater here going to
the few
sure and I just look at it as mahomes
mahomes a reward to lose from here on
out very favorable schedule they play
the four teams of the AFC East the four
teams of the NFC South the home schedule
not all that daunting that the tough
challenges on the road will be a trip to
New Orleans and a trip to Baltimore
where Lamar Jackson and Padma Holmes
will go head-to-head we didn't get to
see it in the playoffs we will see it
for the third time in the regular season
in three years when they get together at
some point in Baltimore
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports